In this lesson, we've talked a lot about
different things that functions can do,
especially different ways that we can
combine them with one another.
Let's pretend like we have these two
functions: f of x equals x cubed, and g
of x equals x minus 2.
We saw that we can combine these through
addition by taking f plus g of x.
We could also combine these through
subtraction, we could either have f minus
g of x, or we could have g minus f of x.
These give us two different things, or at
least in this case they do.
We can multiply them to give us fg of x.
We also found out that we could divide them.
We could find f over g of x.
Or g over f of x.
In all these situations, we just take the
outputs of each function, and combine
them in the way specified.
The other important concept that we
introduced in this lesson was the idea of
compositions of functions.
This means using the output of one
function as the input for another function.
If we want f composed with g of x, that's
the same as asking for f of g of x.
Which means, that we use the output of g,
as the input of f.
In this case, that would give us, x minus
2 cubed.
We can switch things around and go the
other direction too, looking for g
composed with f instead.
That means we're looking for g of f of x,
which in this case, will give us, x cubed
minus 2.
We saw that in many cases, like our
showering and getting dressed example,
switching the order of composition of
functions produces a very different
outcome, a very different output for the
composite function.
Remember, getting dressed and then
showering is not the same as showering
and then getting dressed.
I hope you enjoyed expanding your
understanding of functions and how they
can work together.
Great job.